there have reportedly been tens of
thousands of coronavirus cases at meat
and poultry plants
one investigative non-profit claims more
than 44 thousand workers nationwide
have tested positive for the virus think
about that number for a second and then
more than 200 had died in late april the
president
issued an executive order urging plants
to stay open
since then cbs news has only been able
to identify a couple of plants
that were temporarily closed by
government agencies and one of those
is in california's merced county our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner went there to find out why
anna good morning to you can't wait to
hear what you found out
good morning gail thank you you know
despite what it says was political
pressure
this small county's health department
did what most others have not
closed down a plant due to a covid19
outbreak that claimed some workers lives
he wasn't quarantined for
three days when everything
got worse perla mesa says her 61 year
old father filiberto worked unloading
trucks at the foster farms poultry plant
in livingston for
years until he came down with covid19
in august he went to the hospital then
into a coma
for three days yeah
and
i'm sorry
he later died some 2600 people work at
the plant
merced county public health officials
declared an outbreak there in late june
and during a visit recommended foster
farms test
all of its workers says department
director rebecca nunyanjo kemp
you need to conduct universal screening
of all of your staff you have way too
many staff here
to be able to control one factor you're
being controlled by the factors because
you have so many people here
you want to take control of the virus
within your facility is what you were
saying to them
don't let the virus basically take over
here don't let
illness take over your facility that is
correct did they say they were going to
do it they
did unfortunately that did not
materialize she says
only limited testing occurred in july
two workers died of covid 19.
the county continued to monitor the
outbreak and on august 7th
foster farms provided this list showing
the number of workers
actively infected and those whose cases
they described as
resolved they were giving us this but
county health officer dr salvador
sandoval noticed the list
contained no deaths even though county
health staff say workers had told them
there were more
so the health department emailed foster
farms to ask if there were any known
deaths
and the next week received a new list
this time dr sandoval says
five names previously listed only as
resolved
were now listed as deaths they were put
in a
category that made it difficult for our
investigators to tag them as being
people who had died who put them in that
category the company
what did you think of that well that's
it's misleading and it's and i feel it's
wrong in response the company told us
there was no
intentional effort on the part of foster
farms to deceive the merced county
public health department
and they said all issues related to the
reporting of data were quickly resolved
but now with eight deaths and over 350
confirmed cases
late in august county health officials
told foster farms
the plant would have to be closed that's
when nanyanjo kemp says she suddenly
found herself
talking to federal agencies with one she
says
mentioning the defense production act
part of the president's executive order
to keep plants running
was anybody suggesting to you that that
was the case that look you can't shut
down this plant because
yes i'll be forthcoming yes from the
federal government
correct they were trying to intimidate
we refuse to be intimidated
the whole idea of this is eight people
died
how many more need to die for this to be
an issue you know for us that was enough
the usda confirmed setting up a phone
call with various federal and state
agencies
but did not respond to our question of
whether it pressured county health
officials to keep the plant open
the plant was forced to close for a week
then reopened
under county monitoring foster farms
says it's following public health
officials requirements
and has now hit a testing benchmark of a
less than one percent positivity rate
among its workers
with what it says is now the most
extensive testing program in california
and the company maintains employee
health and welfare has always been
foster farms highest
priority but perla mesa doesn't agree
one of the five names revealed as deaths
on that second list in august
was her father's they don't care
i don't think they care
eight deaths eight
the county says there's been another
death linked to that outbreak bringing
the total
number of workers in its county who died
to nine
now while the county considers this
outbreak to be resolved
the company is continuing to provide
reports to the health authorities there
and foster farms told us it is putting
in place other requirements that were
mandated by the county
including hiring a licensed health
professional to oversee its covet 19
programs
and providing one-on-one covid19
training now
to its employees anthony anna warner
with some very strong reporting there
anna thank you
wow nine deaths now in fact as anna
noted
but really important that the the health
director uh rebecca nyan joe kemp i hope
i'm saying your name correctly
is speaking up because the point she
made how many deaths is enough for us
it was eight eight was enough that's
seven too many yeah
that's eight too many eight too many